[Music]
three
two one action what up guys welcome back
to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want
and today we have eagle man
[Applause]
yup i can see perfectly how many fingers
are holding up
two that was four i can't see the other
hand
oh you can't did you ever uh you can't
be like
how many fingers am i holding up i can i
did
did you ever uh turn into an eagle no
like pull on a mascot's
tail or anything like that as a kid no i
was a nice kid because when i was when i
went to
chuck e cheese as a kid i remember i
kept yanking on the chucky's tail
and then threw one of those masks like
through that screen
where his smile was he goes if you
[ __ ] do that again
i'm gonna beat you up and i was like oh
chuck is scary i think since when i went
to uh
those things as a kid yeah even at
hometown buffet they used to have the
bumblebee mascot they did yeah and then
that [ __ ] will come out
and just the whole restaurant all the
kids will start crying
tormented me as a kid i did not want to
see it i remember the chuck e cheese one
you know how the curtains open and
there's that whole like
oh the rocks concert yeah those were
skit
that she scared the [ __ ] out of me i
have pictures of me with my mom
me crying my brains out with the [ __ ]
things that play like guitar or whatever
don't be like this
i keep looking at your eagles eyes but
then i realize the eye is actually in
the throat
i like how when you go to like places
that are like still like kind of crappy
they have [ __ ] like that where it's like
clearly a screen right there then you go
like disneyland those people are like
legit
you can't see the screen they have like
i think like ac in there and everything
they have ac i heard they have like fans
like you know you have those suits i
have like fans
otherwise like it's hot already like say
in dead of summer that i'm wearing a
tank top and i'm dying yeah the mascots
still come out doesn't matter what the
weather is they still come out
dude that guy in japan died as a mascot
from dancing too hard
that shit's crazy was he like on a ddr
no it was a hot day and he was dancing
like super hard and then he died in his
outfit
oh that sucks it's crazy what a way to
go
dude that's crazy japan's also humid too
oh dude it's like horrible during the
summer yeah
yeah what's worse have you been in new
york during the summer
no but i've been to texas
like houston yeah well uh austin and
um dallas yeah wait no
yeah wait we were in the houston in the
summer too i've never been to houston
during the summer
we did it what about that one time we
did that one show with those baller ass
kids came to pick this up that's austin
oh that was austin yeah oh you because
we went to ut austin
all right that was that was sweaty as
[ __ ] that was humid it was
[ __ ] humid dude yeah i would say
it was worse than texas because um it
was like
wet like it's weird man like asia humid
is you walk outside and you're just
in a sauna or like a steam room
and then you you're just walking three
steps and you already have like sweat
all over your body
you think we're supposed to be in our
normal environment
you mean like how we evolved yeah yeah
we're supposed to be in more
humid areas you think he's supposed to
be in sand and we're supposed to be
yeah i think so because our all asians
in southern california a lot we have
skin issues
because our skin's not used to dryness
yeah but then in asia it feels like my
my skin goes right back to normal we're
not many generations
off from being back there i'm only my
mom my mom they all grew up there
yeah is afghanistan dry i think it's all
different climates
that there's mountains of snowy there's
a lot of snow there's rivers there's
beautiful like forestry there's
everything do we evolved
in that climate wherever our genetic
pool is from for like hundreds of years
so so everything all the migration now
is recent huh
yeah i think so because when i go to any
humid asia environment i feel like i'm
gonna die
i actually like to dry like being here
yeah makes me feel
that's cause you got asthma full always
hot
and i'm super high so when i go to like
like i was born in taiwan right
and when i every time i go to taiwan in
the summer i feel like i'm gonna die
without ac and ac is not even natural
yeah like i don't like when i like even
in hawaii
they're supposed to be relaxing it's
supposed to be hot but i'm like when my
sweat
touches each other i'm just like [ __ ]
dude yeah if there's a breeze it feels
good because it keeps blowing
yeah but if there's ever like just fixed
stale and it's [ __ ] hot oh i hate it
that's how you get those
like super red dark like
uh people that are from there that just
like can like withstand it you know and
like i get dark but i just get
burnt we have to be there for a while
like if i go back to afghanistan
i'm getting super like dark dude
remember that video i showed you about
afghanistan where there was this white
couple they built
a land rover defender like that old
school
tank looking jeep and then um they just
went on a road trip in afghanistan and i
was showing this guy i was like
yo let's go let's do this and he's like
nah we gotta have guns
can you uh just travel there
and you do whatever the [ __ ] you walk
pretty much you can't so it's not like
it's not safe
at the minute you land in the airport
and there's [ __ ]
from the vlog that i watched oh okay
yeah like there's so many parts that you
could travel to they're like
good they have bad things everywhere um
but it's like
it's you just have to be mindful and
then especially being a foreigner it
could be a little bit more you do race
suspicions but
the in muslim culture and especially in
afghanistan
you they treat you like like
i forgot some places like this i saw
this video where this guy was going like
trying to buy some like snacks and food
they wouldn't let him pay because they
knew he was a foreigner they were like
oh no you're our guest
and these people survive on the money
that they get from people
and they're like they wouldn't let them
pay i'm gonna go there if they charge me
i'm like hey my friend nadeem
man i'm supposed to be a guest i want to
go to dubai and like meet someone rich
and play oh that's a dope watch because
then it's like customary like say they
invite you in your home
yeah i forgot where i was reading it or
like watching it but they're like and it
happens a lot
where it's like if you're like uh oh
like that's a nice one and then only
like a super ballers they'd be like oh
take it like because they want to show
like one that's like oh if you like it
like
it's nothing to me like it's it's a gift
here take it you know
dubai is a crazy place i was watching
like so does that mean if they say
hey that's a dope watch i'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] i gotta give up that means hey
don't give me no
not as rich as you only have one don't
give me any compliments
dubai is a crazy place but i like it
because i think for them
if they want something they'll just make
it so like half the islands are man-made
[ __ ] it they even have an indoor um ski
resort they're like
[ __ ] it like everything i'm like that's
[ __ ] tight it's crazy it's like this
is all
racing yeah you go like 20 years ago
desert
20 years ago was just desert yeah they
just make it they're like if they want
something
they'll make it happen which is [ __ ]
tight that means they have a lot of
money
yeah dude that's crazy i want to go
visit all these different places
but i'm afraid of
what kind of news we see here with like
terrorism and [ __ ] like that
but i did watch this moto vlogger she
went from
thailand to europe and she went through
like iran and all these other countries
that
um i thought was always unsafe but it's
actually
super safe where she got lucky or
whatever probably always safe places
i mean it's like america you don't go to
certain neighborhoods here
yeah but how did they how do these
people know like where to go
i'm sure they research if you just go
like this my place looks dangerous
there's a bunch of guys uh in the back
of a
uh truck with guns maybe i don't go that
way i go this way
yeah just yeah be mindful don't like it
just
just don't go like you shouldn't like
those people those people i feel like
you do hear stories where they do end up
dying you know yeah
like there was that stupid ass um couple
that went to go
bike through isis territory to show that
they're like it's not bad and they got
kidnapped and killed
those are the those guys that are like
don't practice common sense where they
think they're superheroes
like that one guy he wanted to you know
there's that one island off of india
that hasn't evolved for
thousands of years oh the scent the
sentinel one yeah yeah yeah and there's
a guy that's like oh i gotta bring
christianity there
and the minute they land there's like a
thousand arrows yeah shot through that
well especially because they're not like
uh they know about
white people yeah so before they they
were good with people so yeah in the
island they
they allowed a person but that guy
brought diseases
raped a bunch of people killed a bunch
of people that's why they're hella
paranoid because there were some weird
missionaries that went there
and raped the people yeah show them
brought health disease so like
no more no more white people yeah yeah i
mean i would travel more to like those
places if i did like have more money or
like
was able to like start a business then i
can like leave
i just need to help with that with the
money part right which is freaking
awesome because
this episode is brought to you by upstar
baby there's a lot of economic chatter
right now about the state of the market
it's recovering
how long will it take have we haven't
seen the worst but if you're struggling
to pay off high interest credit card
debt
you can't wait for those answers and
that's probably the only thing that's
bringing you down
so you need to take action and now with
upstart there's actually something you
can do today
to help fight off high interest credit
card debt upstart is a revolutionary
online lending platform that knows
you're more than just a credit score
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your job history
in the form of a smarter rate upstart
lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online they
offer loans from a thousand to
fifty thousand dollars so you can
consolidate your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment upstart
makes it fast and simple to check your
rate since it's just a soft pull it
won't affect your credit score the halt
the hard pull happens if you accept your
rate and proceed with your application
the best part
if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business day over
half a million people have used upstart
to pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstart
see why upstart has over six thousand
five star reviews on trustpilot and
hurry to upstart.com
record to find out how low your upstart
rate can be checking your rate only
takes a few minutes
that's upstart.com record
your loan amount will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application not out
not all applicants will qualify for the
full amount thank you upstart
that's right uh i'm planning this trip
as soon as things open up and
it's going to be a motorbiking trip from
uh saigon into cambodia
damn that's dope is that going rural
areas
or is that oh that just goes well it's
only like a five hour ride if you go
straight to
from ho chi minh it made it sound so
crazy but we're going to go
like up and down and all because it
might take days it might take days
so we're not we're not doing like the
straight away yeah
so i'd love to do something like that if
i'm able to like stop and like
experience like the different like
cuisines and like explore part of the
city
that's the goal man that's tight because
southeast asia is actually very
like everything's close right like i
mean
if you think about it from here to san
francisco you go to like
if you were in europe or other countries
where they're basically the size of our
states
it's just close like compared to our
distances
so if you're used to doing like a
six-hour road trip or a 10-hour one
then just going off into southeast asia
you can hop a lot of countries
but what we want to do is like go all
over vietnam into the mountains and then
through the cambodian like
backwoods area and then all the way up
to the main city yeah
and it's cool because i have a base in
saigon
and vietnamese speakers and then i have
cambodian speakers
so i feel like pretty safe what if you
need to go diarrhea on a motorcycle
dude imma just pull over did you have
diarrhea the first time you went to
vietnam
no your your gut just handled everything
i i had a stomachache like this
first or second day and it was kind of
constipation but that was it
but everyone gets messed up like
everyone usually gets
sick new bacteria in the food right and
they're not used to it i've been to
southeast asia like
five or six times now though so it i
don't know if it's like southeast
asia food and street food is the same
and i'm fine or whatever i don't know
you have a friend that travels a lot and
he goes whenever i go to like india
he's fine he goes like the slums the
best parts street food everything
whenever he goes to vietnam always gets
always gets uh food poisoning
but what i heard though is a lot of
people
just go to any vendor off the side of
the road
and my friends are basically like
kind of locals now like they've been
there for like 10 years
so they go to all the food spots
that the locals told them that it's safe
so he's like the reason why a lot of
people get sick is they'll just be
like oh let's try this cart or let's try
that versus
uh going to places that they eat at
regularly
because even the locals don't touch
random carts uh
maybe you should start off with like
going to the mcdonald's of that country
and then slowly work your way down to
mama pop and then the
street food vendors yeah because i did
pretty much everything but i also pick
and choose like
for example right if um
they're doing seafood and it's just a
crab that's boiled
highly unlikely that's going to be
something that gets me sick
yeah or like sounds bomb yeah but like
sometimes
there are vendors where you watch how
they watch it
you're like [ __ ] dude i'm risking my
life for this [ __ ]
man i ate boom ball way in a tire shop
dude
what the [ __ ] by day they were a tire
shop where they like
fix tires on scooters you eat it out of
a piece of attire
let's move away it's what we ate right
now that we had it was like red
spicy red soup yeah yeah oh have you
tried it no you gotta try it you'll like
it
it's gonna have pork in it oh yeah yeah
yeah so it's a pork
foot spicy soup right
and um yeah we were in the city oh [ __ ]
i forgot it was not trang or
da nang but it by day time they're a
tire shop and at night
they set up a kitchen and then they just
have these
big ass stock pots boiling and you go
in and it is pretty crazy because
you're sitting and it smells like grease
they just put some freaking benches
and you're eating and the [ __ ] roach
came and crawled up my foot
and i kicked that [ __ ] off and
we're just
we're just eating dude was still bomb
though yeah i mean it tastes good yeah
but a lot of things in vietnam tastes
really good
and there's a lot of things in vietnam
it's like a barber shop in the morning
this is a special place that was just
like a random like
they do two businesses but it's just
weird because like
and i guess like in the states right we
have
all these regulations and like they have
to be a certain way
but like out there it's it's pretty
crazy
what kind of creative things humans can
come up with
um because if you go to the tourist
areas it's more
similar to like restaurants out here
like westernized yeah like the
cleanliness standards and everything
right yeah
but if you just go out to the back
country or whatever
um a restaurant is literally
kitty tables and and and seats and
a ton of ingredients and a lady just
[ __ ]
cooking up at the walk and it's like
there you go yeah
i just want to go and like every country
just hit up like a few spots that like
anthony bourdain went to yeah but the
only thing i heard with that
now is because he made them so popular
that they're killing it with business
but they just can't keep up the quality
or like the
oh it's not the quality but the the
taste demands like like from
how it used to be when i was like just a
smaller mom it was actually really good
that brought him on the show yeah but i
mean that's good for them that they're
probably killing it with business it
just became like a tourist trap
yeah i also heard some of those are like
before you could just go down
and get something to eat but now it's
like two hour wait yeah
cause it's so poppin yeah yeah it's
pretty crazy because
um what we would do is we would get on
our scooters
and we would just hit up different food
stands and then
it's like a doll or two for like a
noodle soup do you guys do the scooters
um each have one or you guys are like
holding each other
in the beginning i was holding him
that's more customary right
yeah we were carpooling because it's
scary man i didn't ride
my own scooter for a week because it was
it was [ __ ] scary
damn yeah but then you get the floor
that's like if you learn here
it's completely different out there way
different
over there it's just like you do
whatever the [ __ ] they're coming on to
oncoming traffic like you're riding and
a dude will [ __ ]
fly through on the sidewalk and you're
just like what the [ __ ]
that's so scary yeah but then you get it
they actually go extremely slow so it's
chaotic
but it's manageable speeds and i learned
in a beach city called danang because
i was too scared to do it in saigon so i
was
i was doing it in an area where it's
actually dangerous because
uh there's less traffic so people haul
ass so people go faster
but i was like more comfortable because
there's less cars
yeah and i learned there and then by the
time we went back to saigon
um i was like [ __ ] it i want my own and
then like i'm tired of riding
behind and holding you what's crazy in
taiwan
like the the crash culture is so
different here i mean over there
know over here like if you crash into
someone it's like what's your insurance
license whatever and it immediately
becomes this big deal and have like a
ton of paperwork
in taiwan you'll see two cars crash and
they come out and like what the [ __ ]
dude what the [ __ ]
all right and they just both leave and
have their bumpers falling off
really yeah they're like it's not like
uh being paid for it yeah they're just
like i think
the the mindset is if you're gonna drive
or ride a motorcycle you're gonna crash
yeah so obviously you don't want someone
pulling out in front of you and crashing
but no one wants to crash so [ __ ] it you
know we'll go fix it on our own but over
here i think it's a
it's very important to figure out who's
right or wrong it's crazy seeing traffic
rules and like customary like
things that they do like i think in
germany or norway say like the highway
is busy
right no matter what they'll leave the
middle lane open just in case emergency
needs to drive
so if it's traffic there's no one in the
middle lane wow they actually respect
that they respect that and then like if
say there is an accident people will
pull over and stuff like that so always
emergency can get through
um yeah just like you care about that
huh yeah and was it in italy like people
they
they have they use their bumpers to push
other cars so they could fit into spots
really i didn't know that that's crazy
i've seen that in taiwan before that's
what a bumper is for to bump him out of
the way
don't [ __ ] hit my landlord but we got
one up here oh yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]